HEARING OF THE COMMITTEE ON
ARTS ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS
TOURISM AND INTERNET MEDIA IS
NOW CALLED TO ORDER. WE HAVE A
FEW HOUSE KEEPING. ITEMS BEFORE
WE START IN ACCORDANCE WITH
COVERT PREVENTION PROTOCOLS WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SCENE IN THIS HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CAPITOL BUILDING. WE HAVE
LIMITED PHYSICAL SPACE IN THIS
ROOM FOR PEOPLE TO WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON AND STILL
PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING SO
WE WILL HAVE A DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY. ADDITIONALLY MASUR
REQUIRED FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS IN
THIS HEARING ROOM FOR THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WE ARE
CONDUCTING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT
IN PERSON HEARING AND ROOM FOR
THIRTY SEVEN. TODAY AND THE
SPACE WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
SEVEN MEMBERS. A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO THAT WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET. THEY'RE ALSO
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND.
AND WE WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THEM MICROPHONE. YOU CAN ALSO
YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING ROOM
ONCE YOU ARE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE FISCAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. FOR DIAL IN WHEN MRS
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS. 877-692-8957
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THE
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL ONE
ELSE ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU
ARE CALLING AND PLEASE PLAN TO
DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS. ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING HIM
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO
BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE A
MAIN WITNESSES PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST A BILL
YOU WERE REMAIN ON A LIFELINE
AND WILL NEED TO MUTE BEFORE
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. I OWES ALSO WANT
TO KNOW WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEING PATIENT WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT NEW METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. DISRUPTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY HAS
EXPERIENCED A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO THE COMMITTEE
AND FOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE
LAST. FEW MONTHS. CONDUCT
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES AT AN
ORDERLY. CONDUCT OF THE HEARING
IS PROHIBITED SUCH CONDUCT MAY
INCLUDE REMOVING A MASK IN
REFUSING TO PUT IT BACK ON.
TALKING OR MAKING LOUD NOISES
FROM THE AUDIENCE. UTTERING
LOUD THREATENING OR ABUSIVE
LANGUAGE SPEAKING LONGER THAN
THE TIME ALLOWED EXTENDED
DISCUSSION OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
HEARING. OR BUILT IN ANY OTHER
DISRUPTIVE ACTS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION. IT'S NOW TIME
TO CALL THE HEARING TOGETHER AS
WE ALREADY HAVE SO WE WILL-
THAT WE ARE NOT READY TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM YET BUT WE-
WELL WE DO HAVE A FORUM- WE CAN
ESTABLISH A COME UP QUORUM IN
THE COMMITTEE SECRETARY WILL
NOW TAKE THE TENANTS.
QUICKSILVER HI WE'RE HERE COOKS
OVER HERE FINALIDAD ES YEAH
POLITICS HERE BLOOM. CHU CHU
HERE CHOI CHOI HERE FRIEDMAN.
WE HAVE A QUORUM MADAM ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL
BEGAN- WE HAVE FOR BILLS TO
HEAR TODAY FIRST ITEM FILE ITEM
ONE WE HAVE S. B. TWENTY SIX-
BY SENATOR SKINNER AND- WE WILL-
SHE'S STILL ON THE FLOOR. SEE
DO WE HAVE. ARE THEY ALL ON THE
FLOOR THEN. OR OR STILL
PROFESSIONAL YEAH WE'RE GOING
TO CALL THE OFFICE. OKAY.
ALL
RIGHT MISTER SENATOR ALLEN
WELCOME AND YOU HAVE TO BILLS
RECENT TODAY WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
START WITH SB SIX ELEVEN INCOME
TAX CREDITS MOTION PICTURES YES
THANK YOU MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE
THIS BASICALLY BUILDS UPON THE
FILM INDUSTRY'S COMMITMENT AND
COOPERATION BETWEEN THE STUDIOS
AND- HI. FOLKS REPRESENTING THE
BELOW THE LINE- INDUSTRY TO
TRAIN AND EMPLOY MORE MORE
CALIFORNIANS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
FOR THE SKILLED WORK TO
COMPRISES MOTION PICTURE
TELEVISION PRODUCTION. HI THE
IDEA IS THAT WE WITH WITH WITH
THEM HI GRADUATES FROM
SUCCESSFUL INDUSTRY TRAINING.
GRAMS THAT HAVE A PROVEN TRACK
pHISTORICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITIES TO
BUILD LASTING CAREERS IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. I'M
SPECIFICALLY IT ACCOMPLISHES
THIS BY PROVIDING A TAX CREDIT
THAT EQUALS 20% OF THE WAGES
PAID TO TRAIN PROGRAM GRADUATES
EMPLOYED BY A MOTION PICTURE
PRODUCTION THE CREDIT WOULD BE
OFFERED. THIS IS IMPORTANT IT'S
NOT CREATING IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
A NEW EXPENDITURE OR NEW LOSS
OF REVENUE BY THE STATE- IT IT
WORKS WITHIN THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK OF THE STATE'S FILM
AND TELEVISION TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM. WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURES OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS. AND DOES SO ANYWAY
THIS IS A AN EFFORT THAT BRINGS
TOGETHER. AS THEY SAY PEOPLE ON
THE MANAGEMENT SIDE THE
PRODUCTION STUDIOS THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNION COALITION
AS WELL. I'M BROAD ARRAY OF
FILM AND TELEVISION IS TREAT
STAKEHOLDERS IT'S RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BOTH.
DEMOCRAT REPUBLICAN FRIENDS- ON
THE SENATE SIDE AND ON THE
PHONE TODAY- TO TESTIFYING
SUPPORTERS WERE SHOT STRIBLING
IS A GRADUATE OF HOLLYWOOD CPR
WHICH IS A- A FILM INDUSTRY
CAREER PATHWAY PROGRAMS. FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE MAKING THEIR WAY
UP THROUGH. THE TV FILM
PRODUCTION WORLD. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL- DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR MEMBERS BEFORE WE HEAR OUR
FIRST WITNESS. A SEEN NONE WILL
GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE MIKE FOR
OUR FIRST WITNESS. WE HAVE OUR
MODERATOR ON. YEAH EIGHTY TWO
MODERATOR I YES IS OUR
MODERATOR ON. MOTORS HERE.
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND OPEN
IT UP TO OUR FIRST WITNESS. THE
LINE IS OPEN. WE'RE ON SB SIX
ONE ONE SENATOR ALAN. THREE
POINT. SHARKS STRUGGLING. YOU
CAN USE ALEXA RECITES STRIBLING.
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE%
SOMEBODY IN THE WAITING ROOM.
JUST WHAT I'LL LOOK TO SEE. I
DON'T SEE EVER SHOT. IN THE IN
THE CALL. OKAY ALL RIGHT AND
THEN- KEVIN HENRY HUDSON. CAN
YOU SAY THAT AGAIN MR MODERATOR.
HEY PLEASE FOR THREE TWENTY
FIFTH OKAY OKAY THAT IT THAT
THAT THAT INDIVIDUALS FOR A
DIFFERENT BILL ALL RIGHT WE'LL
COME BACK AND BRING IT BACK TO
THE SENATOR- IN THE MEANTIME
ANY MEMBER QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I JUST LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT HEROD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR IN DRAFTING DRAFTING
THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. EARLIER THIS YEAR
I SAT ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON MEDINA AND EQUITIES AND WE
EXPLORED HOW WE NEEDED TO
INCLUDE MORE WOMEN AND LATINOS.
AND THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
AND THIS BILL AIMS THEM TO SEEK
IN A GROWING- THIS INDUSTRY
WITH PEOPLE WHO DON'T TYPICALLY
HAVE A FOOT IN THE DOOR- SAID
THERE ARE A LOT OF TALENTED
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN WORKING AND
ENTERTAINMENT FILLED. AND THIS
GIVES AN OPPORTUNITY THE CAREER
PATHWAYS TRAINING PROGRAM AND
PROGRAMS LIKE IT HELP
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND I
JUST GOING TO BE MORE THANKFUL
FOR THAT SO. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR M. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR MOVING THIS
FORWARD AND AS A MEMBER OF THE
API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS WE TO
HAVE ALSO BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON
THESE ISSUES OF DIVERSITY WITH
ENTERTAINMENT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL I THINK- IT
MAKES GOOD STEPS WHEN IT COMES
TO THESE CORE PATHWAYS I THINK
THE ONE THING I WILL SAY THIS
IS NOT ABOUT. THIS BILL PER SE
BUT THE FILM AND TV TAX CREDIT
REALLY FOCUSES- IT'S DIVERSITY
PROVISIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
BELOW THE FOLD WORK- BUT IT
REALLY DOESN'T DO MUCH WHEN IT
COMES TO THE CREATIVE SIDE OF
ENTERTAINMENT WHICH I THINK FOR
ALL OF US WHO FOLLOW DIVERSITY
ISSUES IN HOLLYWOOD WE'RE ALL
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT SO I WOULD
JUST SAY DO HOPE- YOU WITH
OTHER BILLS AND OTHER-
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS TOPIC WE
CAN ENGAGE ON THAT. IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION BUT AS FAR AS THIS
GOES- HAPPY TO SUPPORT IN AND
DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO- TO FOCUS THESE EFFORTS
BELOW THE FULL. THANK YOU AND-
WITH US NOT HAVING IN OUR- OUR
TESTIMONY FROM. A MEMBER FROM
THE AUDIENCE LET'S GO AHEAD AND
BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS FROM
THE AUDIENCE. SORRY FOR THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES THERE
YOU GO GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX ELEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE OUT THERE WARNING
TO BE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION-
SEEN NONE ALL BRING IT BACK.
AND- DO WE HAVE A MOTION. SOME
OF. MOTION AND A SECOND AND I
WILL JUST CHIME IN AS WELL THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY- VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO BE ONE OF THE MOST DIVERSE
STATES AND UNDERSTANDING NOT
ONLY WORK WHEN IT COMES TO ALL
OF THE UNIONS RELATED TO
LIGHTING AND ALL OF THE- TYPES
OF WORK THAT WOULD GO INTO
MAKING A FILM. IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT IN THIS IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTOR TO AS IS
NOTED WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP
WORKING AND OTHER AREAS- BUT
WITH THAT YOU HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY LIKE
TO CALL THE ROLL. SENATE BILL
SIX ELEVEN ALLEN YOU PASSED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION. QUICKSILVER HI QUICK
SILVA I HAVE A BETTER. THE
BETTER FINE BLOOM HI MMHM I CHU
CHU I CHOI HI CHOI HI FRIEDMAN
THIS AREA. THE FIVE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MEMBERS AND NEXT
SENATOR ALLEN YOU HAVE SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT. YOUR SUPPORT ON
SB SIX ELEVEN SO THIS IS
ANOTHER ARTS REALLY BILL MAKES
MAKES SENSE- HERE WE ARE AT THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS BILL- HAS TO
DO WITH- WITH IT WITH WITH OUR
WORK FORCE RIGHT I THINK IF YOU
LOOK AT AT SOME REALLY
INTERESTING THINGS HAPPENING AT
THE NATIONAL LEVEL WITH THE
WITH WITH THE TREND TAKING.
INSPIRATION FROM WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE WORKS PROGRESS
ADMINISTRATION I DURING THE NEW
DEAL WHERE THEY TOOK AS A
MASSIVE ECONOMIC CRISIS AND
USES AN OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST
IN ARTS AND WRITERS AND- SO.
THIS BILL WOULD DIRECT THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL TO
ESTABLISH AND EARN AND LEARN
PROGRAM IN CONSULTATION WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND-
COMMUNITY NONPROFITS TO
EMPLOYEE CREATED WORKERS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES TO ESTABLISH
A- A TRAINING PROGRAM FOCUSED
ON. DEVELOPING MARKETABLE
SKILLS IN THE ARTS. ARE
PRIORITISING LOW INCOME
UNEMPLOYED DISADVANTAGED
PERSONS BEGINNING THEIR
CAREERS. IN THE CREATIVE ARTS-
ONCE AGAIN THE BILL. AT THE ARE
THIS BILL RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE. I IT HAS
BROAD SUPPORT FROM CREATIVITY
SHE WORKER EMPLOYERS. FROM ALL
OVER THE STATE IN HERE WITH ME
TESTIFYING SUPPORTER JULIE
BAKER FROM THE CALIFORNIA ARTS.
ADVOCATES AND ALSO GUSTAVO
ARRIETA FROM ARTS FOR LA. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO AHEAD AND GO TO
OUR WITNESSES FIRST AND SEE IF
WE CAN GET THEM LIFE. THE
MODERATOR HI- YOU CAN GO HOPE
IT AND GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE
LINE. THE LINES ARE OPEN. OKAY
CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS IS JULIE
DECKER YES. GREAT HI SHARE
CLICK SEVEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES AN ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CREATIVE WORKERS
NOT TWO HUNDRED THIRTY BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY TO CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX TWENTY EIGHT ADULT
CALIFORNIA OUR TOPIC IT IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR AND THANK
SENATOR ALAN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THE ISSUE. MUCH HAS CHANGED
SINCE WE GATHERED LAST FOR THE
HEARING ON RE OPENING ART
STAPLETON THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE HAS DONE
TO EDUCATE THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
ISSUES FACING OUR CULTURE AND
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES. NOW THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO GET BACK TO WORK
WE MUST THE FACT WE LEARNED TO
STOP SIXTEEN MONTHS THE REALITY
IS ARTISTIC CREATIVE WORKERS
ARE AMONG OUR MOST VULNERABLE
WORKFORCE WITH HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT. UNDERFUNDING AT
MOST TIMES SB SIX TWENTY A
CALIFORNIA CREDIT WORKFORCE
FACT HAS OPPORTUNITY TO
DRAFTEES AND ACTIVITIES AND TO
BUILD A BETTER MORE JOB
EXISTING ANIMAL CREATIVE
WORKFORCE FOR CALIFORNIA SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT HELP THE POSSIBLE
PROBLEMS ONE IN A DRUG WITH THE
URGENT NEED FOR JOBS IN THE
CREATIVE SECTOR ARTISTS CREATED
WORKERS BECAUSE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE AMONG THE FIRST AND HARDEST
HIT I COOK AT NINETEENTH. AND
ITS ATTENDANT ECONOMIC IMPACT
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR
BLACK INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR CREATED MORE OFTEN
UNDERSERVED AND UNDER INVESTED
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC BY
CREATING LIVING WAGE JOBS FOR
THE IMPACTED WORKERS
ORGANIZATION THERE EXISTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MITIGATE THE
FINANCIAL HARD URGENT COMMUNITY
NEEDS AND LAY THE FOUNDATION
FOR MORE EQUITABLE AND
INCLUSIVE CREATIVE ECONOMY.
SECONDLY SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
REPRESENTS ANINNOVATIVE
SOLUTION TO HELP BUILD BACK THE
ARTS AND CREATIVE INDUSTRIES
OFFERING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
FOR NEW PIPELINE TO CREATE
WORKERS THE PROLONGED CLOSURES
HAVE BEEN DETRIMENTAL ARTS
WORKERS IN MORE THAN JUST
INCOME LOST IN OUR OWN SURVEY
AT THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY. OF
CLOSE TO ONE THOUSAND ARTS
WORKERS THE BROADER IMPACT THE
PROLONGED SHUTDOWN OR MAKING
43% OF ARTS WORKERS RECONSIDER
CREATIVE WORK AND 20% WOULD
CONSIDER LEAVING STATE IF WE
DON'T LOOK TO REBUILD THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA
COULD BE FACING A CULTURAL
DEPRESSION. WE ALSO KNOW
CREATED GUILTY. CREATIVITY
SKILLS CRITICAL TO THE- FUTURE
OF WORK. TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT PRESCRIBER F. SIX
TO EIGHT THE THIRD. HEARD THE
IT THE BEGINNING OF THEIR- WITH.
ARE INCLUDING STUDENT THAT
TRANSFERS SAID. AMONG OTHER
THINGS THAT UNTIL MARKET SKILLS
THE ARCTIC A DENTIST. ARTISTS
ARE OFTEN ON TO CRY OR CUT
COULD BRING EXPERT. TO AREA
COMMUNICATION CONNECTED AND
HOPE. HOWEVER WE CAN TO THANK
AND APPLY BUT NOT IN. PROVIDE
EQUITABLE LIVE WAGE WORK OFF.
WE NEED TO END THE PARADIGM AND
ROMANTICISM OF THE STARVING
ARTIST IT'S SUPPORT THAT YOU'RE
OF THE THRIVING ART. THIS BILL
HELPS ESTABLISH THAT ARTISTS
ARE WORKERS OF THEIR TRADE THAT
TAKES A LONG COMMITMENT AND
BREAKERS JUST A BUNCH IS
VALUABLE AND SHOULD BE SEEN AS
THE FRONT TO WORK. WE HAVE THE
ASSEMBLY ART COMMITTEE WILL
BUTTON SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT TO HELP CALIFORNIA NOT
JUST RECOVERED FROM THE IMPACT
TO THE COMPANY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. BUT EMERGENCY
CELEBRATION CULTURAL EQUITY AND
THE RECOGNITION. AND INVESTMENT
TOWARDS ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST IMPORTANT RESOURCES AND
EXPORT. EXPORT AND CENTRAL
NATURE OF ARTS WORKERS AND THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRY. THANK YOU
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU I NEXT ONE
WITNESS PLEA. ROBERT ATKINS
HEAR ME OK. YES GREAT SHARE
CLICK SO WELL AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
GUSTAVO CARE ACT AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ARTS FOR
LA I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX TO WAIT A
BILL THAT ARTS RELATED PROUD TO
SPONSOR SB SIX TO EIGHT AS LONG
OVERDUE AND WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE SENATOR ALAN
LEADERSHIP AND YOUR PRIORITY
PRIORITIZATION OF THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TODAY ASSEMBLY
ART COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM THE
SON OF TWO THOUSAND OR AN
IMMIGRANT I GREW UP IN LOW
INCOME HOUSING AND SILVER LAKE
AND NEIGHBORHOOD IN EAST
CENTRAL LA. GROWING UP A
CREATIVE CAREER WAS NEVER
DISCUSSES THE POTENTIAL CAREER
IN MY HOUSEHOLD AND ARTS
EDUCATION WITH NOT OFFERED IN
MY SCHOOL I CAN TELL YOU THIS
IS STILL THE REALITY FOR
MILLIONS OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE BURSTING WITH CREATIVITY
AND GROWING UP IN A LOW INCOME
UNDER RESEARCH COMMUNITY TODAY
AT A TIME OF DEVASTATING JOB
LOSSES CREATIVE SECTOR DUE TO
THAT YOU TO THE PANDEMIC WE
MUST EXPAND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS THE
CREATIVE SPECTRUM IN A WAY THAT
BENEFITS THE ECONOMY IN THE
CULTURE OF CALIFORNIA. CRISES
CAN WORSEN PRE EXISTING
STRUCTURAL INEQUITIES SB SIX TO
EIGHT IS A STEP TOWARDS
ENSURING ADDRESS RECOVERY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS WE KNOW THAT
ONE IN SIX JOBS IN LA ARE IN
THE CREATIVE ECONOMY IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SIX THOUSAND JOBS WERE LOCKED
YOU'RE NOT LATE BUT THE
DEVASTATION WOULD NOT EQUALLY
EXPERIENCED AS AN EXAMPLE WE
KNOW THAT BLACK ARTS WORKERS
EXPERIENCED THE LOSS OF INCOME
AT DISPROPORTIONATE. LEVELS
COMPARED TO OTHER GROUPS-
RELIEF CAN BEEN A LIE. FOR
CREATIVE. INCLUDE FINANCE
REALLY FOR SO AND- BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT BY PARK ORGANIZATIONS
OF WORKERS WERE DECLINED
ACCESS. THE FEDERAL RELIEF AT A
HIGHER RATE. SB SIX TO EIGHT
INSURERS THAT. WE PRIORITIZE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO CEATIVE
SECTOR JOBS. WE WILL THAT WE
WILL OFFER EARN AND LEARN
TRAINING TO LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IN OUR FIELD. AND
IT PRIORITIZES THE LIVING WAGE
TO BREAK THE CYCLE OF INEQUITY
FOR SO MANY. THIS BILL WILL
TRULY HELP CALIFORNIA RIGHT
STRONGER FROM THE IMPACTS OF
KOBE NINETEEN. AND OFFER A JOBS
RECOVERY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS FROM
THE COMMITTEE THAT HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR- OR WITNESSES OR
OR- AUTHOR HERE. SAME NONE WILL
OPEN IT UP TO THE PUBLIC. I'M
SURE MEMBERS ALEX TAURUS WITH
STRATEGIES THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION
COMPRISED OF OVER SIX HUNDRED
INDEPENDENT VENUES AND
PROMOTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT
THE BILL SORRY WE GOT OUR
LETTER IN LATE BUT WANTED
INDICATOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT FOR. NOT SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND- I'LL
JUST JUMP IN HERE AND AGAIN I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO NOT ONLY BE A
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE BUT TO
ALSO BE. WORKING CLOSELY WITH
SENATOR ALLEN AS HE IS THE
CHAIR OF THE ARTS COUNCIL AND-
WHAT JOINT ARTS COMMITTEE JOINT
ARTS COMMITTEE I'M SORRY I JUST
GAVE HIM A NEW TITLE THERE BUT
HE'LL TAKE IT EITHER WAY HE'S
BEEN WORKING IN THIS SPACE
QUITE A BIT. AND THE TRUTH IS-
THE TESTIMONIES WERE EXCELLENT.
SIMPLY STATED. BUT YOU KNOW AS
WE MOVE THROUGH COVERT WE-
SOMETIMES I WOULD SAY WE'RE ALL
IN THE SAME BOAT BUT WHAT WE
TRULY SALAS WERE NOT ALL IN THE
SAME BOAT- ANALYTIK NO
COMMUNITY THREE TO ONE THREE TO
ONE WE SAW THE LATINO COMMUNITY
DINE. AND MUCH OF THAT REASON
IS BECAUSE THEY'RE OUT THERE ON
THE FRONT LINES WE ALSO HAVE
SEEN WITH CREATIVE ARTISTS IN
THE INDUSTRY COURSE THAT IMPACT
WAS HUGE IN THE RECOVERY IS
GOING TO BE DEEP BUT THESE TYPE
OF BILLS- CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
AND THE FOCUS ON A CREATIVE
WORK PARKS ACT I THINK IS THE
RIGHT MESSAGE FOR CALIFORNIA AT
A TIME. THAT AS WE REOPEN AS WE
RE IMAGINE IF YOU WANT TO SAY-
WHAT CALIFORNIA'S GONNA LOOK
LIKE POST PANDEMIC THAT WERE
COMING OUT STRONG SANE- WE KNOW
THE CREATIVE ECONOMY IS
SOMETHING THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA
REALLY GIVES IT THAT GLITTER
FROM THE GOLDEN STATE SO WITH
THAT I NORMALLY SUPPORT. THIS
BILL- BUT- WE ASK- IF THERE IS
ANYONE ON THE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OPEN
UP THE LINE DO WE HAVE ANYBODY.
AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PLEASE PRESS
ONE THE DEER AT THIS TIME. AND
WE'LL START WITH LINE NUMBER
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
SORRY THIRTY FIVE NUMBER THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY MR
MANAGER THAT WAS FOR THE LAP
BELT- NO POSITION ON THE- WAIT
WE CAN TAKE THAT TESTIMONY JUST
SINCE I DID FORGET TO OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR THE FIRST BILL BY
THE SENATOR. SURE EDUARDO
MARTINEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX LET. THANK YOU. MISTER
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
ELSE ON THE LINE EITHER SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. NEXT TO A LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CAPITALAND SHOP REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
ARTS EDUCATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX TWENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE MISTER MODERATOR. NEXT TO
THE LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT THE SELECT THE WILD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUM- I AM CALLING IN TO OUR
VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR SB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT AM THE PURPOSE. TO
PROMOTE EMPLOYMENT AND TRAINING
FOR CREATIVE WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AN ACTUAL CAROLINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS BEATRICE CATHOLIC
GRANDMOTHER MOBILISE JUMP
REDUCTIONS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
PONCET MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
SIX TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. A.
N. NEXT GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS NANCY
JOHNSON WITH NIELSEN MARKS MARC
CALLING INTO- CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF THE DIRECTORS GUILD
OF AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
TWENTY EIGHT AND EIGHTY SIX
ELEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR MOTION. WE'VE
GOT A MOTION- BY AS A MEMBER
CHU SECOND BY SOME A MEMBER
BLUE AND YOU HAVE A COMMENT
YEAH. YES I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
OUR SENATOR ALAN ARTIST- BE ON
IS- TO CREATE JOBS BY CREATING.
A GRANT PROGRAM- IN THE BASIS
OF A POTENTIAL JOB CREATION AND
BY TRAINING R. Y. ELLA-
PHONING- TWELVE TO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS OF A PERIOD THE SO
SUMMARY I READ HERE BUT I
WONDER HOW YOU PLAN TO PROVIDE
THE FINANCIAL BASE IS SO FULL
OF THE GRANT. BECAUSE IT'LL
TAKE MONEY YEAH I MEAN IT'S SO
IT'S ONLY GOES IN AFFECTED
SORRY TO THE CHAIR- IT GOES
INTO EFFECT UPON A PREPARATION
OF THE BUDGET- SO WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT. AT WHAT THAT'S
ALL KIND OF- UNDER CONVERSATION
RIGHT NOW THE GOVERNOR HAD PUT
IN SOME MONEY AND HIS INITIAL
BUDGET AND- I'M SO IT'S TIED IN
WITH HIS IT WITHOUT INITIAL
LAST BUT IT'S NOT SPECIFIED
YET. OH OH I SEE SO YOU DON'T
KNOW THE HOW MUCH AND NO-
WHETHER THAT'LL BE- FUNDED BY
THE TAXABLE FROM FROM THE
INDUSTRY- OCCURS- DONATION IS
OF FOUR AS I LOOK A SCHOLARSHIP
FORMAT. WELL IT'S A GRANT-
FORMAT BUT I DO LOVE THE IDEA
OF A OF A- SERVER HYBRID
FINANCING MODEL ALONG THE LINES
OF WHAT YOU SUGGEST MAYBE SOME
PUBLIC PRIVATE FINANCING. I'M
SO. THAT'S STILL THAT'S STILL
BEING AS HAVING WORKED OUT
RIGHT NOW NICE IS THIS IS JUST
AN IDEA THEY'RE SORTED OUT
CREATE THE JOB BUT AN INTERNAL
WHY THEY ARE THIS PROGRAM WILL
ALLOW. THE POTENTIAL ARTESIA
THROUGH TO LEARN. THE INDUSTRY
WELL RIGHT AND TO GET RIGHT AND
STRESS THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S
RIGHT AND WE THERE WAS A-
SIGNIFICANT ASK IN THE ARTS
BUDGET SOME OF WHICH WOULD BE
FUNDED SOME SOME OF SOME OF
THAT SO THAT MONEY WOULD HAVE
TO FIND THIS KIND OF PROJECT.
BOB AS THEY SAY IT'S STILL
SUBJECT TO NEGOTIATIONS. OKAY
SO THE ALWAYS- PROMOTER AND A
SUPPORTER OF- A SMALLER
BUSINESSES OR ANY PROGRAMS SO
AND EVENTUALLY JOB CREATION I
THINK THIS HAS. GOOD POTENTIAL
OF CREATING MORE JOBS SO AS
LONG AS YOU CAN COME UP WITH A
VERY SOUND PROGRAM. NOT ONLY-
INSTEAD- INSTEAD OF FUNDING
pBE GOOD TO GO AND CAR ENCOURAGE
RATHER THAN POORLY RELYING
UPON. A TAXPAYERS MONEY SO I
THINK I SAID I HAVE A SUGGESTED
THAT I THINK THAT THIS IS A
REALLY THE A TYPE OF PROGRAM-
THE INDUSTRY- ITSELF WE SHOULD
BE INTERESTED IN. CREATING
FUTURE JOB WHAT FORCES SO THERE
MAY BE YOU KNOW IF WE CAN
CREATE. OUR LACK OF THE NATION
AND- TAX DEDUCTION AND
ENCOURAGE THEM YEAH YEAH I OR
FOUNDATIONS AS WELL I MEAN I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT MAYBE YOU AND I CAN
SIT DOWN AND GO OVER CUT LEAD
THAT EVERY RIGHT. EVERY GRAYSON
KALRA AND ON THAT BASIS I'LL BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOULDERS. AND
THINK I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE
BILL'S. BUT THE ONLY THING I
WANT TO ADD IS- I THINK IT'S
VITAL THAT WE SUPPORT OUR LOW
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
WITH OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THIS
GRANT PROGRAM CAR PROGRAM A
PROVIDE. A BUT TOO OFTEN WE
FORGET ABOUT THE MIDDLE CLASS
AND HOW EXPENSIVE IT IS TO LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA. I HAVE A GROWING
HOLLYWOOD PRODUCTION INDUSTRY-
AND MY COMMUNITY- AND JUST YOU
KNOW- SOUTH OF US NORTH OF US
EAST US WEST OF US. A LOT OF-
AS PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE TO USE
THIS PROGRAM BUT MY CLASS MY
DISTRICT IS A MIDDLE CLASS
COMMUNITY AND THEY ALSO NEED
ACCESS TO PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
WHICH WHICH WERE AMAZING- SO I
WOULD JUST URGE- YOU AND MOVING
FORWARD TO NOT FORGET. ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN DO FOR MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES AS WELL. YEAH I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AND I
AND I I'M AND YOU MAY BE ONE OF
THE THINGS TO LOOK AT IS PEOPLE
ENTER YOU KNOW KIND OF AT THE
END EARLY STAGES. AND YOUNGER
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT REALLY DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES AND- AND
JUST BECAUSE- NO THEY DON'T
GROW UP IN. ABSOLUTE DESTITUTE
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY CAN'T.
ABSOLUTELY AND- BENEFIT FROM IN
THE FACT. THAT WE NEED A
PROGRAM LIKE THIS SO. I'M HAPPY
THAT TO LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
EXPAND THE LANGUAGE IN A WAY
THAT. HE CONTINUES TO FOCUS ON
ON ON REALLY UNDER RESOURCE TO
NEEDY PEOPLE BUT- BUT DOES SO
IN A WAY THAT'S- THAT THAT'S
MAYBE A LITTLE MORE EXPANDED.
YEAH I'M HAPPY TO DO THAT.
RIGHT THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND AND MADAM
SECRETARY. SENATE BILL SIX
TWENTY EIGHT ALLEN DO YOU
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT QUICK
SILVA HI QUICK SILVA I HAVE
BALLOT THAT IS. PALATABLE FIVE
BLOOM BLOOM I CHU CHU I CHOI HI
CHOI HI FRIEDMAN. THIS AREA
NAZARIAN. THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU YOUR FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT NEXT WE WILL WILL
COME UP US SENATOR SKINNER. WE
HAVE YOU RUNNING AROUND AND
JUST SO THE PUBLIC KNOWS THE
SENATORS ARE RUNNING FROM FLOOR
HERE AND WE ALSO HAVE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS GOING TO OTHER
COMMITTEES. WELCOME SENATOR AND
YOU ARE PRESENTING SB TWENTY
SIX YES THANKS SO MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS SO I'M FIRST
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH MAKE SB TWENTY
SIX AN URGENCY MEASURE. AND
MOVES UP TO MOVE UP THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE TO
SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AND ALL EXPLAINED THAT
JUST A SECOND- IN TWENTY
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA KICKED OFF
STATE ACTION TO RETAKE RESTORED
THE OWNERSHIP OF NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS TO OUR- STUDENT
ATHLETES ALL OTHER STUDENTS
HAVE THAT. YOU ONLY LOSE IT
WHEN YOU BECOME A STUDENT
ATHLETE AND SIGN YOUR CONTRACT
WITH THE AND SEE TO IT. SO
EIGHTEEN OTHER STATES HAVE
FOLLOWED CALIFORNIA'S LEAD-
IMITATIONS GRADES FOR FLATTERED.
SEVEN OTHER STATES WILL HAVE
THEIR LAWS TAKE EFFECT THIS
YEAR INCLUDING ALABAMA GEORGIA
TEXAS ARIZONA. DAY IN DAY GOING
EFFECT EITHER JULY ONE OR
SEPTEMBER ONE. NOW WHAT DOES
THAT DO TO US IF WE KEEP OUR
DATE IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
THEN OUR COLLEGES ARE GREAT
DISADVANTAGE IN TERMS OF
RECRUITING ATHLETES AND ALSO
OUR STUDENTS ARE DISADVANTAGED.
SO WE HAVE BEEN MY OFFICE HAS
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH OUR UC AND
CSU SYSTEMS AND OUR PRIVATE
SCHOOLS INCLUDING STANFORD AND
USC ALL FROM THE LAST TIME
OPPOSED THE BILL. AND THEY'RE
ALL COMFORTABLE WITH THE DATE
OF SEPTEMBER FIRST AND THAT'S
WHERE YOU SEE NO OPPOSITION
FROM THEM- ADDITIONALLY THE
TASK FORCE ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHICH WAS INCLUDED IN
OUR REGIONAL LAW S. B. TWO OH
SIX. THAT TASK FORCE COMPLETED
THEIR WORK AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM ASKED TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE LAW SO I
AMENDED THE BILL TO INCLUDE OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. SO
WHAT S. B. TWO SIX THE BILL
BEFORE YOU TODAY WITH THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS IT MOVES
THE DATE UP UNEXPECTED OF THE
NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS RIGHTS
FIRST STUDENT ATHLETES TO
SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. IT ADDS OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THE DAD'S ATHLETIC
REPUTATION AND WHAT THAT MEANS
IS IF. THE COLLEGE ATHLETE
IDENTIFIES WHAT SCHOOL THEY'RE
AND THEY'RE NOT IT LET'S SAY
THEY HAVE AN AD OR SOMETHING-
OR THEY DO SOMETHING ON YOUTUBE
FOR EXAMPLE THEY DECIDE TO
MONETIZE SOCIAL MEDIA. IT THEY
ARE NOT PROHIBITED FROM
IDENTIFYING THAT THEY ATTEND A
PARTICULAR SCHOOL THAT WOULD BE
A CONFLICT AND THE NC TWO WAY
WHILE THEY'VE NOT ENACTED RULES
YET. THEIR PURPOSE RULES ARE.
NOW LIKE TO MY WITH SINCE.
REALLY HIGH. WHO A FORMER STAFF
VOLLEYBALL START NOW A LAW
STUDENT AT UCLA AND SHE'S ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WORKING GROUP. THANK
YOU GREAT. MODERATOR CAN TWELVE
ARTIST. ILLEGAL OCCUPANCIES
AHEAD OKAY HI THIS IS HALEY
HANSEN AND- I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME PASSED
BY TODAY YOU GUYS HAVE HEARD
VARIOUS ITERATIONS OF TESTIMONY
THE BILL AS OPPOSED TO AFFECTS
AND TWENTY SIX NOW- BUT IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE LIVE UP TO
DATE TO FALL IN LINE- WITH A
GROUP OF OTHER STATES THAT ARE
POPPING ABOUT HALF PAST
LEGISLATION THAT'S GOING INTO
EFFECT THIS SUMMER-
ADDITIONALLY. COVANTA HIT
COLLEGE ATHLETES IN PARTICULAR
VERY HARD- MANY ELECTED TO SAVE
A YEAR OF ELIGIBILITY EITHER
WITHDRAWN FROM SCHOOL ARE
REDSHIRTING AND HAVE ANOTHER
YEAR ENDED MOVING UP THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTATION DATE WOULD GIVE
ALL OF THOSE COLLEGE ATHLETES A
CHANCE TO CAPITALIZE ON THEIR
NAMES IMAGES LIKENESSES AND
ATHLETIC REPUTATION- ADDED
EXTREMELY CRUCIAL TIME IN OUR
ECONOMIC HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY- ADDITIONALLY I DID
SERVE ON MY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WORKING GROUP. FOR THE PAST
YEAR AND THREE THAT WE HAVE ANY
CRITICAL. DISCUSSION- BY. BY A
MARGIN RING BACK. ANSWER THAT
WE CAME UP WITH WITH A ABSOLUTE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. NEED TO BE
INCLUDE IN THAT- AND- THE-
OTHER. BUT OFTEN SORT OF YOUR
BIG FOOTBALL BASKETBALL BIG.
PAC TWELVE SCHOOLS ARE THE ONLY
PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE
ATHLETES BENEFITING FROM THAT-
CRY WE- MANY DISCUSSIONS AND
LISTENING TO MANY. TESTIMONIES
FROM EXPERTS AND PRESENTATIONS
AND LOTS OF RESEARCH ON BATCH
OF SIMPLY NOT TRUE AND WE
REALLY. TALK OF THAT. A GOOD
ECONOMIC RIGHT TO THE CIVIL
RIGHTS AND OTHER HUMAN RIGHTS
ISSUE AND SO TODAY WE ASK THAT
YOU WOULD SUPPORT THE MOVING
THE STATE UP- SO THAT
CALIFORNIA. COLLEGE ATHLETES
CAN BENEFIT FROM EVEN IF I
CANNOT MAKE GREAT ACTING. WELL
THANK YOU. WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. ANY WITNESSES ON
PRESENTING TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. NOPE ALL RIGHT-
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
CALLING IN ONLINE OR IN THE
PHONE QUEUE. AND SUPPORT OR
OFFICE YES. THANKS FOR GO
FORWARD OKAY AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU HAVE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME THE
START LINE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS CRYSTAL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. NEXT ONE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THURMOND YET ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COLLEGES
SHOTS OF OFFICE CONGRESS SPORT
THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON THE LINE TWENTY.
PINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS REMOTE HOME- DIRECTED
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
COLLEGE PLAYERS ASSOCIATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWENTY SIX. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT I SEE NOBODY ELSE WILL
ASK OF THE AUDIENCE ON IN THIS
CHAMBER ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO
COME UP TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. SEEN NONE WE
HAVE OUR MEMBERS HERE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR. JUST MAKE A CUTE A
QUICK COMMENT THAT THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE IN THE SENSE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENED THROUGHOUT. THE
STATE AND WE WANNA MAKE SURE
WERE ALIGNED WITH OTHER STATES
AND GET THIS BILL MOVING THAT
YOU STARTED A FEW YEARS BACK SO
WITH THAT I SUPPORT THIS BILL
SB TWENTY SIX AND WE HAVE A
MOTION. TO HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF ALTERRA
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
AND MADAM SECRETARY. SENATE
BILL TWENTY SIX SKINNER DO YOU
PASSED AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION
QUICKSILVER HI KIRK SILVA I BUT
THERE IS. A BIT OF TIME
BALLOONS. BLOOM I. TO CHOI
SORRY CHOI I FRIEDMAN THIS AREA
HI THE VERY ANTI HI THANK YOU
SENATOR YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU. THANKS MEMBERS. AND THAT
WILL TAKE US TO OUR LAST BILL
AND I THINK ARE WE WAITING FOR
SENATOR RUBIO. SHE'S ON HER WAY.
WE OPEN UP THE ROLE FOR THE
PRIOR BILLS YES. SB SIX ELEVEN
NAZARIAN. I THANK. SB. SIX
TWENTY. AND THERE'S A STORY.
SORRY WELCOME SENATOR RUBIO I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN RUNNING BACK
AND FORTH- IF. ANY WILL BE
PRESENTING S. B. EIGHT ZERO
FIVE SMALL NONPROFIT PERFORMING
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS. ALL AND
PAYMASTER SERVICE GRANTS
EMPLOYMENT GRANTS. TELL US
ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU MEDICARE.
AND I'M SORRY YES THE TEAM
REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE. TO
PRESENT. TO REPEAT THAT THROUGH
A LOT OF WORK IN COLLABORATION
THIS BILL RE FLAX. OF THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE BILL BUT
ALSO TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION
THE COMMENTS AND CONCERNS OF
THE OPPOSITION. MY STAFF AND I
HAVE WORKED MANY HOURS MANY
DAYS AND REALLY HAVE REALLY
COME TO A NICE AGREEMENT THIS
BILL DOES TWO CRITICAL THINGS
FIRST AND ALLOW THE SMALL SMALL
NONPROFIT PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS TO INTER INTER
GRANT PROGRAMS. AS WE KNOW THE
COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
DEVASTATED THESE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THEY WERE NOT
ABLE TO OPEN LAST YEAR AND
REALLY RELY ON FUND RAISING
EFFORTS AND SO THIS BILL REALLY
IS A LIFELINE TO HELP THEM STAY
OPEN AND HELP THEM TAKE CARE OF
THEIR EMPLOYEES. UNDER THIS
PROGRAM THIS BILL FOCUSES ON
THE SMALLEST MOST VULNERABLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND IT DOES
REALLY GIVE THEM. SOME HOPE SO
THEY CAN CONTINUE AND BE
SUCCESSFUL. ONCE IT'S
ESTABLISHED ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONS CAN PAY INTO THIS
PAYMASTER THERE WILL BE CREATED
AND IT WILL ALSO BE COST
NEUTRAL AS THEY ENTER INTO THIS
MASTER PROGRAM. BY CREATING
ECONOMIES OF SCALE
PARTICIPATING NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE ABLE TO
CUT DOWN ON THEIR
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS BY USING
THE SAME PROGRAM. HOLLY'S I
ALSO WANT TO SHARE THAT THIS IS
A LITTLE BIT PERSONAL. TO ME. I
GREW UP IN DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES
AT A TIME. WHERE DRUGS VIOLENCE
EVERYTHING YOU DON'T WANT YOUR
LITTLE GIRL NEXT TO WAS VERY
PREVALENT. AND I WAS A VERY
CREATIVE CHILD VERY EXPRESSIVE
AND I WAS ABLE TO PUT THAT
ENERGY INTO. POSITIVE WAYS AND
I FOUND THE ART. AND SO LUCKILY
BECAUSE I HAVE THAT OUTLET I
WAS ABLE TO DO POSITIVE THINGS
WITH MY LIFE. BUT I ALSO KNOW.
THAT THESE ORGANIZATIONS ARE
REALLY NOT ONLY HELPFUL TO
THEMSELVES BUT ALSO TO THE
SURROUNDING BUSINESSES AND
COMMUNITIES- I STARTED ABOUT
TWENTY YEARS AGO WHEN FASSEL
SAID ONO. AND THE HEART OF
BOYLE HEIGHTS CAME BACK IN A
COMMUNITY THAT WASN'T DESIRABLE
AT THE TIME. AGAIN IT WAS A LOT
OF GANGS AND DRUGS AT THE TIME
BUT I SAW THE LABOR OF LOVE. OF
THESE ORGANIZATIONS NOT JUST IN
BOYLE HEIGHTS BUT ACROSS OUR
STATE AND THERE IS ABOUT. TWO
THOUSAND THAT WILL BENEFIT FROM
THIS PROGRAM. I'M AND I ALSO
WANTED TO SHARE THAT WHEN I WAS.
THEIR ACOSTA TWENTY YEARS AGO
IT WAS INCREDIBLE TO SEE HOW.
HOLE FIFTEEN A LOPEZ WHO OPENED
THIS LITTLE THEATER EMBRACED
ALL THOSE ARTISTS THAT DIDN'T
HAVE ANY EXPERIENCE LITERACY TO
TOOK ALL THOSE KIDS THAT DIDN'T
HAVE A PLACE TO GO. I REALLY
OFFERED A SAFE PLACE FOR THEM
TO COME AND LEARN. REALLY IT
ALSO GAVE A VOICE AND A
PLATFORM TO ALL THOSE ARTISTS
THAT DIDN'T HAVE EXPERIENCE.
THEY WANTED TO GO FURTHER. BUT
I ALSO KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT MONEY. IT REALLY IS
ABOUT EQUITY IN ACCESS TO THOSE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AS
WELL AS SOCIAL JUSTICE I KNOW.
ADDITIONALLY THE PERFORMING
ARTS HAVE BEEN A POWERFUL TOOL
FOR THOSE VOICELESS AND
HISTORICALLY MAJOR SOCIAL
MOVEMENTS IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY HAVE. RELIED ON
PERFORMING ARTS TO ELEVATE THE
COSTS AND TELL THEIR STORIES WE
CAN GO BACK TO THE WOMAN
SUFFRAGE WHEN THEY WERE
ENGAGING WEALTHY AFFLUENT
FAMILIES TO JOIN THEIR CALLS
AND HELP THEIR MOVEMENT TO
BRING EQUAL RIGHTS TO WOMEN.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT WAS
ALSO KNOWN AS AN ERA OF
CREATIVE ACTIVISM. THEY USED
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER THEY
USE THEATER STRONG IMAGERY
POETRY SPOKEN WORD. BECAUSE
THEY WANTED TO CONVEY THEIR
STORY AND WHAT THEY NEED IT. IN
RETURN AT THE OPERA COMPASS
EMAIL. IS A SMALL NONPROFIT
THAT STARTED IN THE FIELD AND
HELPED ORGANIZE THE FARMWORKERS
TO GET BETTER PAY AND BETTER
WORKING CONDITIONS. AND DURING
THIS PANDEMIC A LOT OF THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE NOW THREATENED TO CLOSE
WERE USED BY COMMUNITIES TO
EDUCATE. FOR EXAMPLE PROCESS
SAID ONO AS I STATED IN THE
HEART OF LOW HEIGHTS WAS HIRED
BY L. A. COUNTY TO EDUCATE
ABOUT THE VACCINE AND COVERT
NINETEEN. SO TO ME IT IS
UNDENIABLE. THAT PERFORMING
ARTS GO HAND IN HAND WITH
SOCIAL MOVEMENTS AND PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN OUR SOCIETY.
AT A LOCAL LEVEL THEY PROVIDE
ACCESS TO POOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THE INVITE SCHOOL
THEM PROVIDE CLASSES AND
WORKSHOPS FOR CHILDREN THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. AND AS A CLASSROOM
TEACHER I CAN SHARE WITH YOU.
THAT THE ARTS LITTLE BY LITTLE
HAVE BEEN DISAPPEARING IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND SO WE NEED THESE
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONTINUE TO BE
PARTNERS. AND CONTINUE TO
EDUCATE TO CREATE WELL ROUNDED
INDIVIDUALS. SO TODAY I HAVE
THE HONOR OF HAVING TO
DISTINGUISH GAS. FIRST I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE LARA STOPPER SHE'S
CURRENTLY SERVES AT THE
INTERNET SOCIO DIRECTOR UNTIL
JULY FIRST FOR THE CENTER FOR
BUSINESS AND MANAGEMENT. OF THE
ARTS CLAREMONT GRADUATE
UNIVERSITY AND A LONGTIME
ADVOCATE. I ALSO HAVE MICHELLE.
CRUZ SICK WHO MOST RECENTLY
PLAYED ANNA MAY WONG IN THE
NETFLIX SERIES HOLLYWOOD SHE
PRESENTLY SERVES. THE FBI
DIRECTOR MARK SHOP FOR WOMEN'S
ADVOCATES FOR API ISSUES SUCH
AS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AWARENESS.
SO IF THEY MAY THE AUTHOR OF
MODERATOR. PLEASE WELCOME OUR
GUESTS. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M LORD
SECTOR CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
TO SPEAK IN ADDITION TO BEING
THE INCOME ARE COMING DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTER FOR BUSINESS AND
MANAGEMENT OF THE ARCTIC
CLAREMONT GRADUATE UNIVERSITY
I'M ALSO FORMERLY. THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
ARTS AND CULTURE FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND I'M SPEAKING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
FIFTY AND I JUST WANT TO ALSO
MENTION HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE
THE PASSAGE OF SB SIX TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. SENATOR RUBIO
PEER LEADERSHIP AND WORKING
WITH A LARGE COALITION TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NIZARI AND- FOR YOUR CONTINUING
SUPPORT ON THIS ISSUE AS YOUR
CONSTITUENT FROM SHERMAN OAKS.
I GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
FORWARD THINKING REPRESENTATION
AND I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DIDN'T MENTION SENATOR ALAN.
AND THE OTHER MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE WORKED SO
HARD TO ADVANCE THE ARTS SECTOR.
THIS MEASURES FORWARD THINKING
ON THIS COMMITTEES PART.
BECAUSE IT NOT ONLY IS ABOUT
CORRECTING PAST SYSTEMIC
INEQUITIES IN FUNDING FOR SMALL
THEATERS A SYSTEM THAT MANDATES
SPENDING IS ALWAYS IN RELATION
TO BUDGET SIDE ENSURING THAT
SMALL ORGANIZATIONS STAY SMALL.
AND IT'S NOT ONLY ABOUT
PROVIDING IMMEDIATE CRITICAL
RELIEF FOR THE CURRENT ISSUES
BROUGHT ON BY THAT THE PANDEMIC
ISSUES YOU KNOW THREATEN THE
SURVIVAL OF THE CREATIVE LIFE
BLOOD OF OUR STATE. AND WHILE
IT'S TRUE THAT THIS MEASURE
WILL PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS FOR MORE
THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND OF
THOSE WORKING IN THE TRENCHES
AT SMALL NON PROFITS. IT'S MORE
THAN THAT. IT'S A BRIDGE. THAT
WILL ALLOW SMALL THEATERS TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO EMPLOY
PEOPLE AT LIVING WAGES IN THE
FUTURE BEYOND TO THIS PROGRAM.
BECAUSE OF THESE FUNDS ALLOW
BUDGETS TO GROW IT WILL MAKE
NONPROFIT THEATERS ELIGIBLE FOR
GREATER SUPPORT FROM DONORS AND
FOUNDATIONS. IT'S GOVERNMENT
FUNDING WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
LEVERAGE PRIVATE SECTOR SUPPORT
PROVIDING A PATHWAY TO
SUSTAINABILITY. THE MEASURE
WILL FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
GAME FOR OPERATING THEATRES IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE CRIED
QUADRUPLE BOTTOM LINE OF
BENEFITS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING YOUR COMMENTS IN TAKING
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE OUR NEXT
WOULD WITNESS AND. IN PERSON.
SURE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR A
SEEN ME IT'S ACTUALLY VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME THAT YOU SEE ME
TODAY BECAUSE AS AN ASIAN
AMERICAN WOMAN I AM USED TO
FEELING INVISIBLE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE
AS AN API WOMAN I AM AN ARTIST
BECAUSE I HAVE MOSTLY
EXPERIENCED INVISIBILITY AS
PART OF MY IDENTITY AS AN
AMERICAN AND I FIGHT FOR
VISIBILITY AS AN ARTIST I AM AN
ACTOR WRITER AND NOW DIRECTOR
AND I AM INTERESTED IN CREATING
NARRATIVES FOR MARGINALIZED
PEOPLE AS WELL AS MY OWN
COMMUNITY. MY STORY IS THAT IN
TWO THOUSAND ONE I WROTE A
SOCIAL CALLED MADE IN TAIWAN IT
WAS ABOUT MY CRAZY
DYSFUNCTIONAL FAMILY AND AT THE
HEART OF IT IT WAS A COMEDY
REALLY ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE-
I WOULD THEN LATER GO ON TO
BECOME AN ADVOCATE FOR DOMESTIC
MYSTIC RUNS AWARENESS BUT- THIS
SHOW STARTED MY CAREER IT GAVE
ME CREDIBILITY. GAVE ME ACCESS
TO RESOURCES. AND WHAT I.
DEVELOP TO THE SHOW IN SMALL
THEATERS THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES.
AND LATER TWENTY YEARS LATER I
WOULD BECOME PART OF THE MORE
MAINSTREAM- IDENTITY OF
HOLLYWOOD- BUT YOU HAVE TO
BEGIN SOMEWHERE AND TO FOR ME
AS A YOUNG ARTIST WHERE I
STARTED WERE IT WAS IN THE
SMALL THEATERS. AND NOT
EVERYONE GETS ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES I WAS ABLE TO HAVE.
AND MOST ARTISTS WHEN THEY'RE
NOT WORKING COUPLE EVERYTHING
THEY HAVE SO THEY CAN GO BACK
TO THE THEATER TO WORK. ON
THEIR CRAFT BECAUSE THESE
THEATERS ARE INCUBATORS FOR
IDEAS AND THEY GROW ARTISTS SO
THAT THEY CAN BECOME. AWARE OF
WHAT THEIR VOICES AND HOW TO
HAVE A VOICE IN THE LARGER
INDUSTRY. THEATER COMPANIES.
LINK ARTISTS TO THE AUDIENCE
AND THIS INFRASTRUCTURE IS
VITAL BUT WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT
TO ME IN MY EXPERIENCE IS THAT
THEY ARE BUILDING COMMUNITY.
AND THE CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
UNFOLDING IN THESE SMALL
THEATER COMPANIES. THEY WILL
CREATE A SYNERGY OF EXPERIENCE
THAT THEN PERMEATE TO THE REST
OF OUR CULTURE. IN CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY WE EXPORT CULTURE TO
THE REST OF THE WORLD THAT IS
HOW POWERFUL WE ARE IN THE
ARTS. SO YOU ARE INVESTING NOT
ONLY IN BUILDING THESE
COMMUNITIES HOLDING TO THEM
TOGETHER BUT LIKE SENATOR RUBIO
SAID. GIVING THESE ARTISTS WHO
DON'T HAVE OTHER PLACES TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES. YOU'RE
GIVING THEM A PLACE IN WHICH
THEY CAN BIRTH THEIR OWN
IDENTITIES. AND I WOULDN'T BE
HERE IF I DIDN'T COME FROM THE
THEATER AND IF I WOULDN'T BE
UTILIZING EVERYTHING I
UNDERSTAND FROM THE THEATER
RIGHT NOW AND EXPRESSING THESE
IDEAS. SO PLEASE INVEST IN
THESE SMALL COMMUNITIES DON'T
UNDER ESTIMATE THE POWER AND
VALUE THEY BRING. AND THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO FOR ALLOWING ME
TO BE HERE TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOUR WORK AND
FOR YOUR BRILLIANT UP A
CREATIVE. BEING THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE- TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT DO WE HAVE ANY
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION. SINAN
WE WILL INVITE OUR AUDIENCE IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
CHERRY CREEK SILVA AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I DROVE UP MY
NAME IS MARTHA JENSEN YOU HEARD
ME BEFORE SPEAKING WITH THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON REOPENING
THE ART SAFELY I WANTED TO
DRIVE UP FROM LOS ANGELES TODAY
BECAUSE I REALLY WANT TO THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR WORK OVER
THE LAST FIFTEEN MONTHS. ON
BEHALF OF THE ARTS IN
CALIFORNIA. IT MEANS THE WORLD
TO ME TO KNOW. MY LEGISLATORS
HAVE SUCH DEEP CONCERN. I
BASICALLY WANT TO THANK
REPRESENTED IN THIS AREA AND
LAURA FRIEDMAN WHO'S NOT HERE.
FOR YOUR WORK SPONSORING THE
ONE. I'M SORRY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK SPONSORING THE ONE
BILLION DOLLAR COALITION BUDGET
ASK FOR ARTS AND CULTURE
RECOVERY. OF WHICH THIS BILLS-
AS PETER FIVE IS APART. AND
TODAY I'M JUST REALLY HERE TO
SUPPORT SENATOR RUBIO AND HER
TRANSFORMATIONAL LEGISLATION.
AND I URGE YOU ALL TO CONSIDER
THIS LEGISLATION VERY CAREFULLY
AND TO SUPPORT IT AND DEPOSIT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX TOWARDS
A STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT VENUE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA. WE JOIN OUR
CREATIVE COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE
STATE WERE WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR HER WORK IN GETTING
THIS BILL TO A GOOD PLACE WITH
OUR FRIENDS IN LABOR AND LASTLY
THE SAME WAY THE SMALL STAGES
PROVIDE A PLATFORM. FOR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY CERTAINLY
THAT NORMALLY DO NOT GET THAT
PLATFORM OR INDEPENDENT VENUE
SERVICE THAT FOR MANY MUSICIANS
COMEDIANS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD TO
JOIN IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY- CALLING IN IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN THE PHONE LINES
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AT&T APERTO GIVE YOUR LIFE A
NUMBER OFF LINE AND THE PLACE
YOU BACK IN THE QUEUE. AND WILL
BEGIN WITH ONE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS PRESS OCULUS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT AT AT THE
L. FIVE THANK YOU. EXCLUDABLE
LINE THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN KIRK
SHELDON COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON
THE EDGE OF TRAFFIC AROUND
FOUNDING ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF
AFFILIATE JUMP PRODUCTION
MUMBAI POPULAR ON THE BORDER OF
LOS ANGELES AND SAN BENITO
COUNTY I WANT TO URGE YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL WE
HAVE SO MUCH WE CAN DEAL WITH
LABOR WE HAVE SO MUCH TO OFFER
WE CAN CREATE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS SIMULATOR
GREAT BUT WE CAN'T DO IT
WITHOUT YOUR HELP BECAUSE WE
ARE CHINESE. AND EVEN WORKING
FIFTY TO EIGHTY HOURS A WEEK
WITH MY HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLAR BUDGET I
CURRENTLY HAVE FORTY PEOPLE ON
PAYROLL I CANNOT DO IT I CANNOT
DO IT WITHOUT YOU WE KEEP YOU
UP TO MAKE A BIG. DIFFERENCE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND AS A
FIVE REMINDER LATER GENTLEMAN
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. TWO
SHOW SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
EDUARDO MARTINEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL-
HOWEVER WE UNDERSTAND THAT
SENATOR RUBIO HAS AGREED TO
AMENDMENTS REQUESTED BY THE
ASSEMBLY LABOR COMMITTEE AND WE
WILL BE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION
IF AND WHEN THOSE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED. THANKS SO MUCH
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR THERE
ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM KAMALA CHAIR- WELL THANK
YOU CENTER FOR- BRING IN THIS
BILL WHICH- IS- JUST YOU KNOW
GREAT ELEGANT IDEA THAT WILL
HELP SO MANY PEOPLE IN OUR ARTS
COMMUNITY- AND HELP THE SMALL
THEATERS THAT ARE STRUGGLE
THEY'RE ALWAYS STRUGGLING BUT
THROUGH THROUGH COVERED- THINGS
BECAME DIRE AND NOW. THIS BILL
PRESENTS DEMOCRATS SOLVE ALL
THEIR PROBLEMS BUT IT PRESENTS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO- LOWER
OVERHEAD COSTS- AND WITH THE
LABOR AMENDMENTS- THAT YOU'VE
AGREED TO- SATISFY ALL THE
CONCERNS OF OPPOSITION THIS IS
A GREAT TALENT. A HAPPY TO MOVE.
SUCH A MOTION TO MOVE A SECOND
TO ANY OTHER COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW- CONCEPT
IS- NOT GOOD SUPPORTING ON
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION IN
PARTICULAR AND PERFORMING ARTS.
THERE ARE SO MANY SMALL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS- AND
THE STATE OR EVEN IN THE
COUNTRY. FOR A GOOD CAUSE. R.
AND THEN ALSO DURING THE UP AND
THEN MAKE A- MANY HAVE A CELL
PHONE. BECAUSE OF OBVIOUS OF
FINANCIAL REASONS- SO IT IS OUT
OF COURT TIME THE FORTY TWO
PERCENT- TO HELP WILL IS A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS- AND-
THE PERFORMING ASA- ABOUT THE-
MY ONLY A PERFORMING ARTS A
NONPROFIT SOCIAL KEPT AS THE
STATE HOW. OUR WITH THE
TAXPAYERS MONEY IF WE START
DOING THAT THE ISN'T THERE ANY
EQUITY ISSUE THAT THAT. I CAN
COME UP WITH THE OR THE A
SIMILAR APPEARANCE OF ALL OTHER
SECTORS. HOW CAN WE MANAGE TO
FUND ALL SMALL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS SO IF WE STOP THE-
TAKING OUT THE A SPECIFIC CAR
INDUSTRY. WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION AND
THAT YOU KNOW OF COURSE I WOULD
LIKE TO SAVE EVERY INDUSTRY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER GRANT
PROGRAMS FOR DIFFERENT. REASONS
YOU KNOW THERE IS GRANT
PROGRAMS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND SO IN PARTICULAR I CHOSE
THIS- BECAUSE YOU KNOW I WAS
INTIMATELY INVOLVED WITH THESE
ORGANIZATIONS- AND I FELT TO
MENTION THAT I ACTUALLY
PERFORMED MYSELF INTO THEATER
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND I SAW
FIRST HAND WHAT THEY DID TO
OUR- INNER CITY COMMUNITIES THE
VALUE THEY BROUGHT HOW THEY
KEPT THEIR KIDS OFF THE STREET
AND TEST. THE POWER THAT THEY
BRING TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR SO FOR ME IT WAS ABOUT
TRYING TO CONTINUE THE GOOD
WORK THAT THESE COMMUNITY ARTS
PERFORMING ARTS- ORGANIZATIONS
DO TO HELP THE UNDER SERVICE ON
PARTICULAR FOR ME THAT'S BECAME
IMPORTANT AS I MENTIONED AS A
TEACHER. I SAW THE ARTS
DISAPPEAR AND I KNOW HOW VITAL
IT IS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE OUR KIDS SO FOR ME THE
CHILDREN ARE INNER CITY
COMMUNITIES WAS TO WHY I WANTED
TO DO THIS BUT- I AGREE WITH
YOU WE NEED TO HELP A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND WHAT THIS IS JUST
CREATING THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
SMALL NONPROFIT COMMUNICATORS
TO HELP THEMSELVES WE'RE JUST
SETTING THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WHICH THEY WILL PAY A FEE TO BE
PART OF AN UNTAPPED. AND AGAIN
THIS IS JUST GIVING THEM A LIFE.
LINE FOR THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS. THANK YOU OF US. MEMBER
AN ASSYRIAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IDEA I'D BE REMISS IF I
JUST DIDN'T POINT OUT THAT-
FIRST OF ALL- SMALL THEATERS
ARE SMALL LITTLE HUMAN
LABORATORIES- NOT JUST FOR THE
PERFORMING ARTS BUT FOR MANY
OTHER VITAL- COMPONENTS OF WHAT
MAKES US INTO DECENT HUMAN
BEINGS- MY WIFE AND I ENJOY
GOING TO. FIRST OVER FORTUNATE
TO BE LIVING IN A PLACE WHERE
THERE ARE MULTIPLE SMALL LITTLE
THEATERS IN THE AREA PART OF
THE REASON FOR THE SMALL
THEATERS IS BECAUSE IT'S THE
ACTOR'S FUTURE ACTORS AND
ACTRESSES. WORKSHOP AS THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
PERFORM AND TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
A CAREER SLOWLY- IN SMALL STEPS
SO IT'S EXTREMELY VITAL FOR US
TO SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS AND
THEN SECOND. IF WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT DOLLARS AND- AND HOW
VIS A INVESTING IN THESE
PROGRAMS COME BACK TO BENEFIT
US- I WOULD LOVE TO SEE NUMBERS
BECAUSE I DO KNOW THE EXIST. ON
TO WHAT EXTENT SUPPORTING SMALL
THEATERS GENERATES MONEY BACK
LOCALLY. BECAUSE FOR EVERY
PERFORMANCE THAT STARTS AT
SEVEN SIX PM THERE ARE DINNER
RESERVATIONS STARTING AT FIVE
FIVE THIRTY IN ORDER FOR PEOPLE
TO GO OUT. ENJOY A MEAL
TOGETHER AND COUPLES OR SEVERAL
PEOPLE AND THEN GO OVER THANK I
SEE RESTAURANTS PACKED- ANYTIME
THERE ARE PERFORMANCES- LATER
ON IN THE NIGHT ESPECIALLY
FRIDAY AND SATURDAY NIGHTS AND
SUNDAY. SUNDAYS NIGHTS AS WELL
SO- I VERY MUCH SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND- LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND- TO
CONTINUE MOVING IT FORWARD. HEY
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND-
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS. ALL JUST MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS IN THE SENSE THAT I
REALLY WANT TO APPLAUD THE- ARE
SENATOR- WHO IS ALSO A FORMER
ELEMENTARY TEACHER AS I AM AND-
THEY SAW FIRST HAND. WITH OUR
SMALL NON PROFIT- ARTS VENUES
NOT JUST THEATER BUT OTHER
STORYTELLING ALL MEET MUSIC.
HOW IT REALLY CAN CHANGE LIVES
I KNOW THAT THERE WAS A DONOR
IN FULLERTON WHERE I TAUGHT FOR
MANY MANY YEARS HE WOULD
SOMETIMES BUY UP. A GOOD LOT OF
TICKETS THAT WEREN'T BEING USED
AND I WAS ABLE TO TAKE
STUDENTS- THAT I HAD FOR THREE
YEARS IN A ROW SAME STUDENTS I
HAD FOR THIRD FOURTH AND FIFTH
GRADE. TO NOT JUST ONE
PERFORMANCE BUT MANY
PERFORMANCES AT THIS LOCAL
MUSICAL REPERTOIRE AND THOSE
STUDENTS NOW WHO ARE YOUNG
ADULTS HAVE SAID THAT SOME SEEN
THIS LIVE PERFORMANCE AT THE
LEVEL IT WAS REALLY WAS LIFE
CHANGING. SO WE KNOW THAT THE
ARTS CAN CHANGE LIVE WE KNOW
THAT IT IS ALSO PART OF OUR
CREATIVE ECONOMY. BUT THE ARTS
ARE ABOUT STORIES ABOUT OUR
LIVES AND WE JUST SEE THIS
BLOCKBUSTER MOVIE COMING OUT IN
THE HEIGHTS BUT THAT PARTICULAR
ARTIST AND DIRECTOR AND
PRODUCER ALL OF THEM STARTED
SOMEWHERE. AND THEY DON'T
ALWAYS START ON BROADWAY MANY
OF THEM START AT SMALL
NONPROFIT THEATERS AND THAT'S
HOW WE BUILD THAT DIVERT
DIVERSITY IN ORDER TO SHARE
THOSE STORIES THAT REALLY ARE
OUR AMERICAN STORIES. SO WITH
THAT- I NOT ONLY SUPPORT S. B.
NUMBER IS A- FIVE EIGHT OH FIVE
BUT I THOUGHT THE- US SENATOR
FOR HER DILIGENCE AND WE HAVE A
MOTION. AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY. SENATE BILL EIGHT OH
FIVE RUBIO DO YOU PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT QUICK SILVA HI QUICK
SILVA I VALID ADDRESS. VALID AT
A FINE BLOOM BLOOM I CHU CHU I
CHOI. CHOICE A NO FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN AYE NAZARIAN. HI YOUR
BILL IS OUT AND. WE HAVE WILL
KEEP THE ROAD OPEN FOR AND-
SENATE BILL INCUBATOR SIX
SKINNER- CHOI- I'M SORRY CHIU
BY TWO BY THREE POINT FIVE
FRIEDMAN HI. SENATE BILL SIX
ELEVEN ALLEN FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
HI. SENATE BILL SIX TWENTY
EIGHT. FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN HI.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT BUSINESS BEFORE
THE ARTS ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS
TOURISM AND INTERNET MEDIA
COMMITTEE IS NOW COMPLETE AND
THE HEARING IS ADJOURNED.